el invierno ha regresado a la población
de orane y con él La pesadilla para
narizza que después de ocho meses la
única noticia que tiene de su hijo
Alexander es esta carta recibida por
intermediación de la Cruz Roja
Internacional en la que solo dice que
está vivo y saludable pensamos que podía
estar en velarus buscando a su hermano
detenido con él cuando recibimos esta
carta subimos que él estaba vivo esta
población campesina al norte de kiev
estuvo en control ruso hasta el 26 de
Marzo cuando sus fuerzas se retiraron
del norte de Ucrania ese mismo día
Alexander Fue capturado junto con su
hermano menor por todo al pequeño lo
enviaron a un orfanato en velaruzo
porque no sabían Qué hacer con él y
cuando logré traerlo de vuelta a Ucrania
nos contó que pensaba que su hermano
tenía las costillas rotas
771 civiles están oficialmente
desaparecidos desde el 24 de febrero se
sabe que al menos 479 están en prisión
en los meses de calor me sentí mejor
pero ahora vuelven mis miedos qué hacer
aquí puede ver que esta coyuntura se
curó por su cuenta los fragmentos no
fueron sacados
Natalia hace parte del equipo del centro
por las libertades civiles esfuerzan su
trabajo en desaparecidos no militares
que por lo general no aparecen en la
lista de prisioneros que Rusia presenta
para intercambiar
estoy más segura que la mayor parte de
esta gente está en lugares de captura y
otra parte están los territorios
ocupados en Ucrania eso primero lo
segundo lo que más temo ahora mismo es
el invierno y sabemos en qué condiciones
Vive esta gente Hoy es un día en el que
el esfuerzo de ocho meses de búsqueda ha
dado sus frutos aunque con un final muy
triste para la familia
lo último que supieron de ella es que
quedó herida el 24 de marzo en bucha
bajo el control ruso para los familiares
es un gran alivio poder decir adiós y
saber qué fue enterrada bajo las
tradiciones ucranianas es muy importante
pero el dolor de esta familia no termina
el marido de ludmila Igor de 62 años
también es uno de los prisioneros
civiles en las cárceles rusas